شكرا السي اهلا بكم مشاهدينا جحر الديك
الذي كنا قد تحدثنا عنهه من قبل في فيديو
مختلف للقسام يعود للواجهه من جديد بفيديو
جديد لاشتباكات من مسافه الصفر وشاهدنا
لاول
مره كتائب القسام ومقاتلي القسام وهم
يقتلون جنديا اسرائيليا باصابه مباشره في
هذه العمليه سنعرض لهذا الفيديو لكن هنالك
ايضا فيديوهات اخرى من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
وسنقاره لما زعم جيش الاحتلال انه احتجاز
واستسلام لمسلحين سنعرض لكل ذلك كله مع
ضيفنا اللواء فايز الدويري اهلا بك اللواء
فايز ونبدا بجحر الديك هذه
المره وهذا الفيديو الجديد الذي عرضناه
قبل قليل ونعرضه
للمره الثانيه الان لعمليه القسام من
المسافه صفر لهذه التجمعات لجنود الاحتلال
والتسلل خلف خطوط جنود الاحتلال بهذه
الصوره
والهجوم على
مخيماتهم ماذا يمكن ان يقال في هذا
الفيديو يعني اولا انت اشرت الى جحر الديك
وهذا ليس الفيديو الاول هذا جحر الديك
دخلت له القوات جيش الاحتلال في اليوم
الاول قبل 47 يوم وا يفترض ان تكون منطقه
امنه اذا تبنينا وجهه نظر جيش الاحتلال
وها هي ليس الفيديو الاول ولا الثاني ولا
الثالث وبالتالي كان اصبحت كما يقال شوكه
في خاصره جيش الاحتلال هذا الفيديو اي جاء
بنا بعد تصريح ل القسام وتحدث عن هذا هو
الجندي نعم جندي الاحتلال الذي قالت
القسام انها قتلته القسام تحدث عن مقتل
عشره اي بمعنى اخر هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
قد تكون بمستوى قياده المنطقه او او
القوات المتواجده لكن الفيلم يعرض زاويه
واحده يعرض خمسه جنود يتقربوا حفاه يصلوا
الى نقطه الكشف يكونوا في وضعيه اخذ الارض
يراقبوا يطلقوا قذيفه تي بي جي بعديها
اطلاق نار ومن ثم يتقدم اثنان منهم يصلوا
الى الخيمه يقتل الجندي ياخذوا يسحبو خارج
الخيمه ياخذوا سلاحه بقيه مم 16 ميم 16 و
بالتالي عمليه تقريبا متكامله رقم رم نعم
رقم البندقيه و والشعار وغير ذلك وبالتالي
هي جزئيه من مشهد اكبر لكنها احد
المقاربات التي تم تصويرها واعدادها
وبالتالي هي عكست طبيعه العمليه بصوره
كامله بينت مستوى المهاره في الاداء
والاصرار على تنفيذ المهمه والعوده ولكن
الملفت في ال انهم لم ياخذوا الجثه ولم
يابوا بها لانهم ستكون عبع عليهم في
العوده او لديهم او ربما اخذوها
لانه لم لم يحملوها تركت لا لا تركت في
منطقتها لانه يعني اولا قد يسبب لهم عبئ
في العوده حمله اثنين يبدوا ليسوا بحاجته
يبدو ل لكن راينا لاول مره جنود القسام
وتحت اقدامهم جندي اسرائيل نعم نعم هذه
احد منذ العمليه منذ بدء العمليه البريه ه
هذه يعني الان
الفيديوهات مختلفه حسب الواقع هناك دبابات
ميركافا النمر الى غير ذلك عمليات قنص في
مناطق مبنيه لا هذه في منطقه مفتوحه يعني
منطقه جحر الديك هي منطقه زراعيه مفتوحه
على مساح ايضا م السيارات يعني كيف يمكن
لعمليه في هذه المنطقه المفتوحه ان تتم
بهذه واضح ان هنالك اريحيه في التنفيذ اين
مسيرات الجيش الاحتلال يعني الان هذا
يعطيك ما هو نوعيه وكم التغذيه الراجعه من
نقاط الرصد للقسام وبالتالي تقدم لهم
المعلومه شبه كامله يتم اعداد القوه هؤلاء
الخمسه لتنفيذ جزئيه من من جندي واحد قتل
بينما عشره في مواقع وقيم مختلفه وبالتالي
تعطيك اولا الكفاءه في البعد الاستخباري
وتقديم التغذيه الراجعه التي يبنى عليها
تجهيز المج
الجماعه ومن ثم تظهر عندك مستوى المهنيه
والاحتراف والاصرار
والتضحيه لدى المق هذا من جانب القسام لكن
من جانب جيش الاحتلال هذه المسيره التي
قتلت الزميل سامر ابو دقه بالامس واصابت
الزميل وائل الدحدوح كيف بها لا تستطيع ان
تحمي جنود في منطقه مفتوحه ويتسلل اليها
القسام من الخلف كيف ل جارفه الدينا تدوس
الخيم والنازحين فيها هذا يكون يكون صاحب
اليد العليا تجاه العزل ولكنه صاحب اليد
الدنيا تجاه المقاتل هو يثب يظهر شجاعته
ودمويته وحبه في الاجرام امام العزل اما
عندما يواجه المقاتل لا فهو اجمل من جبان
هذا جحر الديك لدينا ايضا فيديو
ل الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقول انه
لمعارك دارت في الشجاعيه نشاهد هذا
الفيديو لنلاحظ الفارق ما بين فيديوهات
القسامه وفيديوهات الجيش الاحتلال هذه
طبعا فتحه ربما يزعم جيش الاحتلال انها
لنفق وانه قد تكون لنفق لا انكر ذلك قد
تكون لنفق وتم كشف فانت لاحظ الارض مجرفه
وبالتالي عندما تم جر في التربه ظهرت ال
الفتحه امر طبيعي جدا ان يجدوا فتحه نفق
ولكن السؤال ما قبل الوصول لها هل لاحظت
الجندي وهو يطلق النار على الارض هل لاحظت
الجندي وهو ويلقي القنبله اليدويه ها هو
انظر انظر ه هل هذا جندي في جيش محترف هزم
الدول
العربيه سحقا يعني تقول انه يده يده
مرتعشه نعم يده مرتعشه على حتى الجندي
الذي يطلق الارض على على التراب على الرمل
بعد تجريف من الجرافه هذا يدلك على انه
يعني جندي جبان خائف من كل شيء وهو قتل
ثلاثه من الرهائن اها قبل موضوع الرهائن
يعني حت حتى في هذا الفيديو
لم نرى الجهه الاخرى هذا الفيديو هذا
الفيديو الذي اذعه جيش الاحتلال والفيديو
السابق الذي اذعه داخل المدرسه نرى جنودا
يطلقون النار مره على حائط مره في الظلام
في طرق ط احدى الطرقات المظلمه والان حفره
ربما تكون نفق لكن لا نرى في المقابل لا
اطلاق نار من الجهه الاخرى ولا ولا اشخاص
اين هم المقاتلون هذا الفيديو رقم اربعه
اشاهده واحلل اه في الاربع فيديوهات بما
في هذا الفيديو لا ارى طرف المعادل الاخر
فقط ارى صور جنود جيش الاحتلال باداء معين
وفي الاربع فيديوهات كان الاداء سيئا يعكس
عدم المهنيه وعدم الاحترافيه والجبن
والخوف طيب اليس من الطبيعي ان ينزلوا الى
هذا النفق لو كان حقيقه عمليه عمليه
عسكريه انت ذهبت الى نفق واطلقت النار
وقلت ان به ارهابيين كما تقول هل من
الطبيعي ان تترك هذا النفق وتذهب د تقاتل
داخله لو كان مقاتلا جريئا يجب ان يدخل
الى النفق لكن هو اجبن من ان يدخل النفق
لماذا لان هناك اربعه او خمس محاولات سواء
اثناء فتح غطاء النفق بالامس الفيديو الذي
دخلته ما ما يسمى قوات الصفوه او النخبه
ومعهم كلب تم قتلهم استدراجهم وقتلهم
فبالتالي كانوا اجمل من ان يدخلوا الى
النفق حتى لو كان به صيد هذه العمليه يعني
هذا الاطلاق حول النفق والقاء قنبله في
فتحه النفق ما قيمته عسكريه انا اكون
متلهفا ومتشوق ان ينشر جيش الاحتلال كل
يوم عشر فيديوهات تعرف لماذا لانه يكشف
انه جيش فاشل في الميدان وفي الاعلام انا
اتمنى ان ينشر يوميا عشر فيديوهات لانه
اشعر بنوع من الرضى الداخلي عن مستوى هذا
الجيش وبالتالي هذا الجيش الذي كان يشكل
تحديا الان لا يشكل تحدي امام عده الاف من
المقاتلين طيب هذا هذا ما ما رايناه هذه
مقارنه طبعا المقارنه الواضحه ان هنالك
قتال في فيديو القسام قتال فيديو يب يبين
طرفي المعادله يبين طرفي المعادله هنا لا
نجد الا طرفا واحدا لكن هنالك فيديو ايضا
لجيش الاحتلال فيه طرف اخر هذا الطرف
الاخر سنعرض هذا الفيديو الان هو ما زعم
انه لمسلحين
يستسلمون من حماس في في مدرسه هذا هو اه
هذا فيديو المست هذا هذا الفيديو فيديو
القسام هذا هؤلاء ابطال
القسام يعني شيء مثير للسخريه اذا اذا كان
الجن الاسرائيلي لا يستطيع ان يخطو خطوه
واحده دون اطلاق النار اذا كان يطلق النار
على ثلاثه رهائن ينادوا باللغه العبريه هو
الان يتحدث عن اسر المئات من القسام
اتحداه ان يظهر مقاتل واحد من القسام طبعا
تم تفنيد من
بعض المختصين هذه
الفيديوهات التي نشرت سواء هذا او غيره
وايضا انا انا اشاهد ما يتعلق بالسلاح
نفسه مشاهد مقرره وفيها ايديت كثير انا
اشاهد المئات من من ابطال القسام استسلموا
وهذا الشيء مثير مثير للسخريه يعني انا
قلت لك اتمنى ان ينشر ع فيديوهات يوميا
هل هذا الجندي هو نفس الجندي اللي اطلق
النار على الثلاث الرهائن طيب هو يقود
المئات نلاحظ هنا ان هؤلاء مجردون من
ملابسهم ويفترض ايضا انهم مجردون من
سلاحهم طيب اذا كنت لا تقتل المجردين من
ملابسهم الذين يرفعون الرايات البيضاء
المستسلمين
ا فكيف قتل جيش الاحتلال ثلاثه من
المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في غزه رغم انه اعترف جيش
الاحتلال بانهم ايضا كانوا متجردين من
ملابسهم وكانوا يرفعون الر ال